We saw earlier that pods
can be restarted for
all kinds of reasons like
fail liveliness checks,
readiness checks, a command,
and this leads to a problem.
What happens if we want to
communicate with a set of pods.
When they get restarted it might
have a different IP address.
And this is where services come in.
Instead of relying on pod
IP addresses which change,
provide services as
a stable endpoint for pods.
The pods that the service exposes
are based on a set of labels.
If pods have the correct labels,
they are automatically picked up and
exposed by our services.
Now, the level of access the service
provides to a set of pods
depends on the services type.
Currently there are three types.
There is cluster IP
which is internal only.
There's tight node port which gives each
node an external IP that's accessible.
And then there's type load balancing
which adds a load balancer from
the cloud provider which forced traffic
from the service to nodes within it.
Okay, it's time for
you to learn how to create a service and
use label selectors to expose the limits
set of those pods externally.